Drama! Intrigue! False identities and whole
new personas! Sounds like the plot of a real
pot-boiler suspense novel. Or, idk, an episode
of WandaVision. But those are just some of
the reasons why real authors take on the hallowed
nom de plume, also known as the pen name!
To some people, the idea of a pen name seems
kind of weird. If I, a writer, am going to
put countless hours of hard work and thought
into my modern masterpiece, Hype House Blood
Bath, and I manage to catch the eye of an
agent or publisher who likes it—why wouldn’t
I want to put my own name underneath the title?
Why wouldn’t I want the world to know it
was me, Jimmy Squibbles, who toiled long and
hard on a 80,000 word epic about the pain
and suffering of being a Pocky influencer?
I have nothing to hide!
But from Stephen King to Ben Franklin to …., who
had their own secret aliases, to Mark Twain
and Dr. Seuss, whose aliases became so famous
that they are remembered by their pen names
and not their actual names, the nom de plume
has a long and proud history in the literary
world.
Think of them like the original YouTubers—some
want to go by their real names, and some want
to create an online identity that connotes
less of a person and more of a brand. ….
While works written under anonymity or published
under a pseudonym might feel like an anomaly,
much of the history of literature itself owes
itself to works without attachment to real
names. In his book Anonymity: A Secret History
of English Literature, author and professor
of English John Mullan muses that:
A good proportion of what is now English Literature
consists of works first published… without
their authors’ names. These works are now
collected in bookshops or libraries under
the names of those who wrote them, but the
processes by which they were attributed to
their authors are largely forgotten. It is
strange to think of… Pride and Prejudice
or Frankenstein being read without knowing
the identities of their creators, but so they
once were…
Mullan goes on to explain that this fascination
with pen names reached a zenith in the mid-19th
century, with scholars going so far as to
compile every piece of anonymously published
writing they could get their hands on, with
Scottish librarian Samuel Halkett compiling
anonymous material for a sort of dictionary
called the Dictionary of Anonymous and Pseudonymous
Literature of Great Britain. It clocked at
a massive nine volumes, all of which were
exclusively originally anonymous works. And
says Mullan, since its first print publication,
every well known-English author has been tied
to an entry within its pages.
So why would someone take a pen name, then,
since it seems to have been a trend as ubiquitous
as YA books titled (noun) of (nonu) and (noun).
Well, there are lots reasons. So, let’s
examine some notable examples of noms de plume
and why the real people they were attached
to were drawn to using them.
Sometimes you have easy examples—Joseph
Conrad, who wrote Heart of Darkness (terrible
book), was originally named Jozef Konrad Korzeniowski
— and when he began publishing his works,
which were written in English also coincided
with him becoming a British subject, he anglicized
his name to reflect that. Much to the chagrin
of other Polish thinkers, who felt it disrespectful
to his country of birth.
Some authors take names to hide past dramas
that actually happened to them in real life—like
author O. Henry, whose short stories often
concerned the minor tribulations of everyday
people living in New York City. Behind the
small, romanticized misunderstandings of
his fictional worlds was a man named William
Sydney Porter. Porter already had an established
writing career as a humorist, but after being
arrested and jailed for embezzlement, picked
up the pen again while in prison as O. Henry
in a bid to conceal that he was publishing
stories while incarcerated.
Then you have writers like Theodor Geisel,
who while he had several pen names he worked
under, is most universally adored as children’s
author Dr. Seuss. Geisel took the name from
his mother, born Henrietta Seuss, while he
was an undergraduate at Dartmouth College—and,
despite how we pronounce it now, originally
pronounced it “SOICE”. He changed it to
“SOOS” when he realized, in his own words,
that the pronunciation “evoked a figure
advantageous for an author of children’s
books to be associated with—Mother Goose.”
And then, just for funsies, added the Dr.
to his name as a joke…. dad had wanted him
to become a doctor. Sorry, dad.
Some of the largest figures in modern popular
literature took pen names to differentiate
new works that didn’t fit the tone of what
they were most famous for—among these authors
are mystery writer Agatha Christie, who published
romance novels as Mary Westmacott, JK Rowling,
who ….. Sigh, … published her mystery-thriller
Cormoran Strike novels under the name Robert
Galbraith, and, perhaps most amusingly, Stephen
King, Our Boy™, who posted several works
as Richard Bachman.
At the beginning of King’s career, it had
been something of a truism amongst publishers
that an author publishing more than one novel
per year would be distasteful to an audience.
King, who like a shark that will die if it
stops swimming, will die if he stops writing
EVEN IF HE’S IN THE HOSPITAL CONVALESCING
FROM A NEAR FATAL CAR ACCIDENT jesus -- convinced
his publisher to let him publish several titles
as Richard Bachman. And when the ruse was
found out, King announced that Bachman had
died from “cancer of the pseudonym” and
wrote a book around him called The Dark Half.
Then there are those who take pen names for
metatextual reasons, like Daniel Handler,
who is best known to readers around the world
as Lemony Snicket, the author of the A Series
of Unfortunate Events series. But the goofy
name wasn’t chosen just for purposes of
whimsy. Lemony Snicket is himself a character
and part of the narrative of his own stories,
and his elaborate, false identity is woven
in and out of the books just as much as the
actual protagonists.
Then there are authors who take pen names
to try and reconcile with their own identities
from birth. The Bronte sisters, for example,
all wrote their only novels under matching
gender-ambiguous pseudonyms, with Charlotte
publishing Jane Eyre as Currer Bell, Emily
with Wuthering Heights as Ellis Bell, and
sweet forgotten Anne with The Tenant of Wildfell
Hall as Acton Bell! Said Charlotte on why
the Brontes decided to make pen names a family
affair:
We had a vague impression that authoresses
are liable to be looked on with prejudice.
On the opposite side of this is poet and writer
Sapphire, author of Push. Unlike the Brontes,
Sapphire, born Ramona Lofton, picked a name
that not only embraced her identity as a Black
woman but also pushed back on stereotypes
of Black women, saying:
I took the name Sapphire at the height of
the New Age movement, when everybody was a
gemstone. At one time in African-American
culture, the name also had a very negative
connotation. Sapphire was, like, the evil,
razor-toting type of belligerent black woman,
which was somehow attractive to me, especially
because my mother was just the opposite. And
I could picture the name on books; I couldn't
see "Push, by Ramona."
And then there are pen names that come from
a melange of ideas, like writer and activist
bell hooks, born Gloria Jean Watkins, who
said of her nom de plume:
When the feminist movement was at its zenith
in the late 60’s and early 70’s, there
was a lot of moving away from the idea of
the person. It was: let’s talk about the
ideas behind the work, and the people matter
less. It was kind of a gimmicky thing, but
lots of feminist women were doing it. Many
of us took the names of our female ancestors—Bell
Hooks is my maternal great grandmother—to
honor them and debunk the notion that we were
these unique, exceptional women. We wanted
to say, actually, we were the products of
the women who’d gone before us.”
And sometimes—just sometimes—pen names
are straight politics. The Federalist Papers,
published between 1787and 1788 and written
to urge the ratification of the United States
Constitution, were all published under the
name of Publius. And if you remember
10th grade history or, heck, seen Hamilton,
you probably know that Publius is the pen
name of Alexander Hamilton, James Madison,
and John Jay.
The authors chose to do this not just for
the sake of anonymity itself, but in the name
of tradition at the time—many defenses for
and arguments against ratification were published
under pseudonyms, often taken from Roman antiquity
because those founding fathers just couldn’t
help but simp the Romans. And Hamilton himself
very pointedly chose Publius as a nod to one
of the four aristocrats who led the overthrow
of the Roman monarchy.
In her book examining the subject of pen names,
bluntly titled Nom de Plume, writer Carmela
Ciuraru muses:
“To a certain extent, all writing involves
impersonation—the act of summoning an authorial
“I” to create the speaker of a poem or
the characters in a novel…But some writers
are unable to engage in such alchemy, or don’t
want to, without relying on an alter ego.”
There is a lot of theoretical discussion on
how an author’s private life and choices
are intrinsically tied to the work they produce,
and how the two play off of each other in
the minds of readers, publishers, and those
who wish to biographize them. And so goes
the pen name, which—as we have seen, even
with this incredibly limited survey of authors—often
springs from deeply personal and unique reasons
respective to the author’s life.
There are authors for whom a pen name felt
necessary and then went onto regret them,
like Toni Morrison, born Chloe Wofford. Though
she took the name while studying it at Howard,
Morrison had this to say later in her life:
”People who call me Chloe are the people
who know me best,” she says. “Chloe writes
the books. Myself is kind of split. My name
is Chloe. And the rest is… that other person.
Who is able to feel, or pretends to feel,
or maybe really feels, or at least reacts
to celebrityhood.
And then there are those like George Sand,
born Amantine Lucile Aurore Dupin, who became
one of the most popular writers in French
Romanticism under a male-sounding name, who
also dressed in male attire, and who eventually
began to sign personal letters as George Sand.
Said her contemporary, Victor Hugo: “George
Sand was an idea. She has a unique place in
our age. Others are great men ... she was
a great women.”
And then, sometimes, there is just no explaining
a pen name entirely. It’s taken as fact
that one of the most famous American authors
and employer of a nom de plume, Mark Twain,
had lifted his moniker from the riverboat
terminology for a measurement of “two fathoms”.
And while the author has said as such in his
autobiography, scholarship doubts that claim
on the basis of … well, Twain himself, who
also said it was literally lifted from a dead
man—in this case, a steamboat captain named
Isaiah Sellers. To quote a letter written
by Twain:
“Capt. Sellers used the signature, “Mark
Twain,” himself when he used to write up
the antiquities in the way of river reminiscences
for the New Orleans Picayune.
He hated me for burlesquing them in an article
in the True Delta; so four years later, when
he died, I robbed the corpse--that is, I confiscated
the nom de plume. I have published this vital
fact 3,600 times now. But no matter, it is
good practice; it is about the only fact that
I can tell the same way every time.
The line between the author as a public personality
and the private person behind the pen is often
blurred, and a subject that raises many questions
and sometimes an unfair or dangerous degree
of the public trying to read between the lines.
For many authors, a pen name presents a solution—an
easy way to delineate between the story-teller’s
brand and the regular person tapping away
at a keyboard, trying to finish a manuscript,
and hoping someone sees the truth in it.
If you like It’s Lit, you should check out
Otherwords, the newest addition to the Storied
family! Otherwords dives deep into the world
of linguistics and language. Have you ever
wondered about what makes words, well, words?
What about how computers “talk,” or the
unique characteristics of different dialects?
Check out Otherwords (and be sure to tell
them that It’s Lit sent you). Link in the
description below.